[Music]
this
is sharing your story part two pudding
pen to paper
this is one of our workshop series for
application week
my name is will torres i'm one of the
admission officers here at the stanford
graduate school of business
and over the course of today my hope is
we will all like get a better
understanding of how writing fits in
the application process especially if
you're thinking about the gsb
so in session one so
starting your story i talked a lot about
getting an
understanding for what is your
quote-unquote big picture
what's your journey what does it look
like if you look backwards
what were those footsteps what did that
trail look like what was the environment
around the trail look upwards what's
your north star
be comfortable with all of those details
and spaces
so that's a lot of detail so
how do you distill that into the written
parts of the application
um it sounds like it's going to be a
tough situation but
i hope that by the end of today you are
going to be inspired to
kind of think deeply try different
things and see
what fits what feels good and pursue
those and allow that to like
channel and focus your energy on what
you're putting down on paper
so that's what we're going to be doing
today session two putting pen to paper
so a little bit about today's session we
will be recording it and posting it to
our
uh youtube channel so i definitely
recommend to check that out it's one of
those hidden gems
there's a lot of great content both in
terms of admissions
as well as what's campus life like
in lieu of visiting campus in person
sometimes these videos are some of the
best glimpses of the things that happen
and the energy that you're going to
experience during your time at the gsb
so over the course of the day i'm going
to talk a little about the writing
what does it look like how does it fit
in with that review process
the holistic review process that i've
been talking about um
every session this week we're gonna talk
about content and style
notice that i'm not breaking up our
sections into
essay 1 essay 2 optional questions
we will talk about those but even this
structure is intentional
my hope is that we are going to think
beyond just you know
what matters most to and why but think
about
each opportunity um in that writing
landscape was a chance to tell us
something about yourself
definitely gonna start talk about tips
takeaways tactical practical
and um i've tried my best to weave in
questions that we've had through the
week
and over the course of my career were
the ones that i've seen rise to the top
pretty frequently
and embed those into today's session so
let's get this going preface there
is a lot of advice out there take
everything with a grain of salt
take even the advice that i'm giving you
today with a grain of salt
this is not an end all be all and
this is the way to get into stanford
session
but rather my hope is to provide um
different frameworks
ways for you to think through step back
and kind of tackle it from a new
direction if you get stuck
this is really to empower you and try to
help you
self-coach through this process so
this also i can only speak for stanford
some of the tips and recommendations in
all honesty are also
mine um but hopefully these are things
that you can also use
throughout your life whether you are
applying to school or maybe you're
applying their job
or you're just thinking about what's
coming next in life hopefully some of
these things will come in handy along
the way
so writing in the holistic review
process this is
going to be a definition that you've
seen through the week holistic
characterized by comprehension of the
parts of something as intimately connect
interconnected
and explicable only by reference to the
whole
what that means in the admissions
process at stanford is that we are
taking a look at
everything that you submit for us to
really get to know and understand you
it's not a process where we're looking
at one thing kind of screening from
there looking at another thing and
passing it through
but really taking all the pieces to
really understand
okay how do these elements of context
come together for us to understand okay
here is how this individual's
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
come together
in our evaluation process it is not a
formula it's not an equation or
algorithm there are no benchmarks
cutoffs or quotas so we're not saying
hey we need x amount from this industry
or we're only going to take
x amount from that country that's not
how it works
we're really looking at you as an
individual trying to bring
together a talented dynamic exciting
group of people
to learn and kind of grow together
no one part of the application
necessarily means more than another
and i think this is where sometimes that
essay
starts to loom really like darkly over
like your anxiety over what can happen
next
it is not a make it or break it piece we
are using the essays
in conjunction with the other parts of
your application to understand who you
are
we are not grading your written portions
as good
or bad but really using those in an
opportunity
to learn more about you that's one of
those things that
i really care about learning about you
so when you're out there kind of doing
research hearing things talking to
people
and you hear someone say hey this is the
essay that got me in
kind of take that step back and realize
okay that's an essay as part of an
application that got them in i've been
in this line of work long enough that
i do remember applications i do remember
people and sometimes i hear people say
that
i see them kind of in newspapers or
publications and i
i remember those files and sometimes
it's like oh
all right that's a that's a cute thought
so some people get in
despite their essays and some people are
unfortunately unique we're unable to
admit despite a
a really well thought out introspective
um really
like thought out essay so really take it
as a whole really
blowing up those parts admissions
recommendations are made on the
evaluation of the application as a whole
if i didn't hammer it in enough let's
highlight that last part
as a whole okay intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential
personal qualities and contributions
these are the things that we are looking
for throughout your application
so if you haven't done so already uh
check out the evaluation criteria
section of our admissions webpage
there's a lot of really great language
to help unpack
and really give you new perspectives for
how to understand these
somewhat kind of mushy like phrases and
really see how they might come to life
for you
in our application that's why we're
looking all of these different pieces
come together for us to get that picture
of who you
are how you're going to show up in that
on on campus
when it comes to writing you're really
going to be focusing on
these four parts essays resume
activities work
history and optional responses notice
that i highlighted that section did a
little bit of
kind of shading there to really hi it's
optional
we have admitted people who have not
filled those out um we have admitted
people who have filled them out
it really all depends on your journey
the things that you're trying to share
and the information that you want us to
know about you
so i'm gonna hit pause there for a
second
if you feel like uh you have a pretty
good
understanding of how the holistic review
process works
uh can you jump into the q a box and
type in the name of any animal
just throw it in there i want to make
sure that hopefully
people are getting a sense for the theme
that's happening awesome obviously
zebras count as elephants
there's actually no reason that i chose
animals other than to keep y'all
on your toes if you do have questions
about the holistic review process
think those through please put them into
that q a box as well
i go through the questions afterwards to
see hey where are other places that i
can work on
to make sure we're able to convey the
the knowledge and information that we
need to so
any information questions um animals i
love animals just pop them in there
so thank you for uh
letting us take that quick time out now
let's talk writing so content like what
is it
i should be writing about remember that
big picture of who you are
how do we start to figure out which
details are gonna be
the most helpful so i often get asked
questions and they fall into
a couple of buckets here like should i
be talking about personal things
should i be talking about professional
things what's the right
balance um should i focus on details or
a bigger picture
the answer i give is surprisingly common
across
all of those and it's up to you
why this is such an open-ended answer is
that
everybody has their own journey for one
person
your response might be informed more by
your personal experience
for someone else that balance might
swing more towards that other direction
and for me to prescribe some kind of
percentage or balance or way that you
should be
kind of answering these i think takes
away some of that agency
and really does you a disservice but
that doesn't mean we're leaving you
hanging so take the questions
as your guide think of them as your
friends
we put in a lot of effort to make sure
that the questions are asking
what we're looking for and we're really
not trying
uh to ask for any hidden questions it's
not a trick
at all but really how are we learning
about you
through the lens of this question so
let's go through that in a little bit
more detail
let's give it a little some some meat on
those bones so
what are these sections asking here are
those kind of major written portions of
the gsb
application let's start with the resume
and the activities and work history
here we're really trying to understand
what have you done personally what have
you done professionally
and i like to think how these two work
together
i've often heard people say hey it feels
kind of redundant
there's information that i'm copying
back and forth
um and then i like to step back and
think
these are two opportunities for you to
share information with us
take a look at those two materials do
they necessarily
have to say the exact same details word
for word
yeah things like your title or the times
that you worked
and where might be the same but there
are different types of information that
you can convey using both pieces
so if you think about it that way use it
as an opportunity
so you know think through what do i want
stanford to know about
me let's do this in a little bit more
again i'm not going to leave you hanging
so what should you include here again
up to you by that i mean
you're the only one who knows what are
the most meaningful things that you've
done
what are the things that you find the
most important what are you proud of
and then as you think about that like
why are you proud of it how did you get
to that place where you're able to do
those things
you know some of those musings that can
come handy later on as people are
curious to know more about your life
what are some of the things that shaped
your perspective there is a
questionnaire application about hey what
you know are
the what perspective do you bring to um
to the class
we'll talk a little bit more i'm
stumbling because i want to make sure i
get that phrasing right
because the wording is important to help
you understand what we're trying to get
to
and then impact we talk a lot about
impact
and that can mean anything like how is
whatever space you're in how's it
different from your
presence what are things like scope
scale
depth context what are some of those
details that might be handy for us to
know about you
if in doubt if it's important to you
it's important to us
so let's talk a little bit again step
back that holistic reminder
we do not have a preference for where
you've worked what organizations you
belong to what school you might have
gone to
so it's not about the name or stature of
that organization
but what is that what are those
footprints that you have left behind
as you think about that and connect that
with the intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential
personal qualities and contributions
all of those things background agnostic
context dependent and what do i mean
like by that
those three things can pop up anywhere
in your life
and one of the things that i love about
the stanford evaluation process
is we'll recognize and celebrate that
wherever that might be for you
so maybe it comes with your church
involvement your mosque your synagogue
maybe it's in a club or organization
maybe it's something
you do at home there is a lot of
leadership
competencies that you might be
expressing in your home
situation as well so never underestimate
the different places that you might be
making an impact
that context piece is that the way that
your you know some of these qualities
might manifest is going to look
different depending on where you are
so leadership might look different if
you are a current college student
versus if you are working and you have
been with your company for nine or ten
years
just because you're in different places
in your life doesn't mean one is more or
less valuable
we just understand it'll look different
and that's okay
we want you to kind of understand where
you are
because that's where that starting point
for growth is
okay let's talk resume
i know we often focus our attention on
the essays
but for the gsb application it is a
like a standard business resume try to
keep it to one page wherever possible
that said there are some unique
circumstances extenuating circumstances
where maybe
two pages might be appropriate so the
first one that people tend to think
about is if you've had
10 or more years of work experience
another one
sometimes you might have had
publications or
like a book or you've written articles a
white paper
and those citations as you write them
out like who are the authors
what year was it what what was that
journal that takes up space
and so personally i think that's helpful
information and i know our staff does as
well
so sometimes there's instances where it
might be appropriate to go
kind of into that second page again we
trust your judgment
there is a flexibility here we're not
going to dock you because you go onto
that second page
but really try your best um one page
being succinct and direct and clear in
what you're trying to communicate
is also a skill set that you're going to
need to leverage as a business leader
so there's no better place to start
practicing that than your resume
visual impression so this is already
trending us into that like style
and how do i approach it this kind of
overlapped in that venn diagram
but if you're thinking about content how
much writing should i put in there
to step back take a look is it helpful
or is it are you hoarding and just
adding all that detail
right we are humans reading on this end
of the spect on this side of the table
so make sure that as you're writing
things are clear that's easy to read
you can definitely shoot margins if you
need to but sometimes that tiny tiny
font
or cramming in a lot of words can make
it really difficult to pull
out the critical information that i
should be learning about you
we do not have a resume format that we
require or ask you to do necessarily
similar to the way you all have
different journeys through life
sometimes that does necessitate a little
bit of creative license and freedom to
make sure that you're able to convey it
in a way that's appropriate for you some
industries might emphasize one thing
others might emphasize another we want
you to make we want to make sure you're
able to
kind of speak your truth in all of these
spaces
so i have a little exercise here uh i
actually really love doing um resumes
this is something
this is like a thing that has come about
pretty recently
i think i think it's really fun um
so we're gonna play a game it's called
who do you know more about
we have two individuals all right
individual a and individual b
a manages an aquatic conservation
program that is that bullet point
on their resume person b you know in
that same
bullet point space created a public
private action plan
that saved seven fish species from
extinguishing
this might be a little obvious and i
don't want to be too facetious with it
but i thought it would be kind of fun to
throw up a poll so i'm going to
put that out there we're gonna launch it
who are you learning more about
from these one or two lines okay it
seems like it's a pretty clear answer
um there's a couple of folks that are
are putting in a which
you know might is fine as well
um but my point with this is there are
ways
for you to describe the same job like
when i made this example
this i actually have the same person in
mind and this is something that i often
see in resumes
um so i'll go ahead and stop this photo
thank you for
um entertaining that thought but
when you're in your resume what's that
bullet point doing
is it describing what you do like versus
what did you do
there's a slight nuance there sometimes
when you're describing
like this is these are the things that i
do it's more of a job description versus
hey here are the things that i have done
what are some of those impacts
that's when you're starting to see you
know if it's quantifiable that's when
the numbers come into play
so really try to think about impact and
you know
how you have left those organizations
different or change them
and that might be one way for you to
think about okay
how can i get maximum mileage out of
that limited real estate on
my resume and again each one of you has
a
different different format just ensure
that it's clear easy to read and that
the things that you want us to know
about
you know are you can you can take those
away
all right now let's get into the essays
and the optional responses
i know there is a lot of questions
myths um this is where a lot of myth
busting happens
and so let's let's go here right let's
get deep let's get in the weeds so
let's start with the essays what matters
most to you
and why and why stanford
earlier i talked about letting these
questions be your guide
and notice they are not prescriptive
they are not
asking you for what matters most to you
in a business context
it really is what matters most to you
and why i'd like to encourage all of you
to
emphasize and why um because that is the
question that's what we're asking
there is a difference between what
matters most to you and here's evidence
for it
versus here's what matters to me and
here's that introspection and reflection
that helped me really understand you
know who are you
because of we did an exercise in sharing
your story one
where we listed different things and
kind of talked to them as individuals
saying
because of you i am and really helping
you and path how those instances might
have impacted who you are
right and that's where that what matters
most you and y comes from
dean moss talks about a body of research
that taught that says
some of the most successful leaders out
there are the ones who lead from a place
of mission
and values and purpose what are yours
this internal dialogue that you are
engaging with in this question
is also going to be reflective of some
of that internal dialogue that world of
feedback that you're going to be
engaging with
at the gsb in that leadership curriculum
you know why should someone
follow you draws that attention inward
and hopefully this question is doing
that as well
why stanford two words so many places
you can go with them
maybe the subtext here is why stanford
for you
yeah center yourself in all of the
responses
some folks might you know the mission
might resonate for them for others it's
because
their ability to explore and pivot into
another place is going to be facilitated
by the stuff here
we have no expectations um we
don't think one rationale is more
important or compelling than another
what i want to learn about is what are
your motivations
for coming here right and so that's
where
that comes from i want to learn about
you
okay there are the optional responses as
well and so where
these came from i think helps illustrate
you know how we're
thinking about the essays and these
responses as a way to learn about you
kind of you know in a really interesting
way
so what we found in the past is that the
what matters most to you and why
essay people were putting in their
accomplishments in
there um which you know definitely
things to be proud of
but they didn't always necessarily
connect with the things that mattered to
them
so it almost felt like um they were
shoving a round peg into a square hole
so that's where
these optional responses came in
especially that impact one
we want to create a separate place
because we do want to know about that
we do want to know about the impact
you've created but we also want
you to be able to answer this the
questions kind of
in there on in with honesty and truth
right and not how
to try to squeeze or um kind of mix
things up just to get all of these bits
in
so what are these questions there we go
think about times you've created a
positive impact whether in professional
extracurricular academic or other
settings what was your impact
what made it significant to you or
others
pretty clear cut here we're asking you
directly
and one of the things here is that you
don't necessarily have to
use flowy pros take how much space you
have and how much runway
um as a clue to like hey maybe this is
where
i can be more direct maybe i'm just
giving the facts
so that they know and right away what's
going on what's the context scope
scale um why is this meaningful and
significant
the second one tell us about a time
within the last three years when your
background influenced your participation
in a situation interaction or project
again very clear about kind of the
context and circumstances that we're
asking you
but also very open-ended when we say
background you know that could be
anything about who you
are again in session one of uh starting
your story
um we practiced and went through a
couple different exercises
so that you might be able to think
through okay hey who am i
and what does that mean as i think about
both business school and
life beyond and that could be one place
to go if you'd like a little bit of
inspiration
uh for if you want to go through this
optional question
okay i'm going to call this section
quick questions so this is actually
drawn from things this week
and we're going to speed through this
and hopefully it'll cover some of the
questions that you have in the q a box
right now
so do my essays have to connect what if
i talk about the same things
will it be redundant we're gonna go
through these um one by one and we're
gonna like
hammer them out do my essays have to
connect
the answer is no sometimes the things
that matter the most to you
don't aren't the reasons that you want
to go to stanford
and that's fine we want you to use those
spaces
in a way that makes the most sense for
you
what if i talk about the same things
will it be redundant
so you can talk about the same thing
especially if you're coming from it from
different angles
there might be details about maybe a
bullet point in your resume
um some of that contextual situational
kind of those ripple effects
that you might want to include in your
impact questions or somewhere in your
essay
or maybe there is something you refer to
in your essay but more in that personal
sense
but there is also impacts and
repercussions of it
maybe that's where you add additional
detail in the impact side so really
thinking beyond just
one part of the application to really
understand like hey
these are different ways i can add in
depth and nuance even if it's about a
single thing
right sometimes those single things can
be really meaningful
um both for you and the people around
you
how vulnerable is to vote this is up to
you
this one is a little bit again up to you
i would say
what am i learning about you through
this process
again it's less about what
and more about the so what who are you
what am i learning
i really appreciate um this question i
get asked it a lot
um my own like personal request is you
only need to add the
amount of detail to let us know what is
going on
um i really appreciate that because you
never know who's reading on the other
side and you want to be thoughtful to
not
potentially trigger um other experiences
they might have had
so just be thoughtful um that goes for
like the details that you're adding as
well
give us enough so that we understand the
situation
and then focus on you know you
what if my story is complicated
sometimes this goes hand in hand with
these other pieces
the additional information section can
be your best friend
maybe it is a a term during college
where you had an
extreme health crisis maybe it was
something else going on in your life
maybe it is some of these extenuating
circumstances that inform your
something that you've written but don't
necessarily fit in
with the flow that you have use that
additional information space
like judiciously but include any
relevant bits of information that you
think we need to know so that we really
understand you
bullet points are your friends here this
is not a additional
essay it's additional information be
concise
again let us know what you think we need
to so that we really understand
your circumstances how much explaining
is too much explaining i kind of refer
to this in some of our previous
responses
what am i learning more about you or am
i learning about the situation
in the holistic review process i want to
know about you
and who will see my writing so the
admissions
staff and you are the only people who
are going to see it
and whoever you share with it share it
with personally
we don't share this with faculty not
part of the
evaluation process we are trained
professionals
not even your alumni interviewers are
gonna see it
all they see is your resume and you know
exactly what goes on there
so know that this is a safe confidential
space that if you do want to go
somewhere vulnerable or if you're
talking about something maybe for the
first time
if it's something that you know maybe
the world doesn't know about you but you
want
you want to discuss it with us you can
and we're not going to be sharing that
with anybody
okay so that was uh quick questions
how do i stand out from the crowd this
is that next question i get all the time
so center to yourself i talked a lot
about that embrace your journey and be
true to your reasons and rationale
discuss the things that are meaningful
for you
just if i had a quarter for every time i
said the word you
in these presentations hopefully that's
an indicator for where we're going with
like
what we're hoping um we're getting out
of this uh journey with you
so and dig deep this is where those
interesting bits come out this is where
even if we all say something like family
the way we've engaged with that and your
own experience with family is going to
be different from mine
it's going to be different from
everybody on this call so
really go there and understand the who's
in house of what you are
so we're gonna do a quick exercise um
you might have done this with me before
or somewhere else if you have done it in
the context of
uh the gsb application try it with a
different topic
but what we're going to do is i'm going
to ask you a question i'm going to turn
my camera off so if you want to grab pen
and paper so you can jot something down
open up another browser or just sync
along i'm gonna turn my camera off so
that i don't distract you too much i
want you to be able to get into that
zone
i'll give you um reminders and cues for
what to do next
and then we'll take it from there don't
need to think about it
too hard just really the first thing
that comes to mind
what matters to you
lowering the stakes on this question it
doesn't even have to be what matters
most to you
but what matters to you just give you a
couple of seconds
so that you can drop something down
there i think your way through it
all right now let's get to the fun bit
why
i'll give you about a minute so that you
you can
jot your thoughts down and really start
to unpack
your first response
all right start to wrap that thought
take a deep breath give yourself a
moment because i'm going to ask you
another question
why that do you just give me what
matters to you
why you know why that think
if there was a child asking you
sometimes they're they're asking why why
why bring that childlike sense of
curiosity
to this question
go ahead start wrapping that thought up
take another deep breath let that one
out
take me one level deeper
why that
all right so go ahead and complete that
thought
i'm gonna continue because we have some
more content that i really want to share
with you all
but if you get stuck and you're just
curious and you want to try something
different
try this continue ask yourself again
and then ask yourself again get down to
that fifth why
usually even by the third fourth fifth
why those are when you're going to be
talking about things that only you can
talk about
and you don't necessarily have to put
those things in the application
but as it broadens your um understanding
of things
maybe there are a lot of things that
matter to you maybe try
try this exercise and see what are is
there a
fundamental common theme across them you
might be surprised at what you find
right so we don't have a preference for
how you approach this we don't have a
preference for what you share
we just want you to share what is
most important to you and why i know
there's a lot of questions here
about the spirit of the question and we
did talk about that briefly
whether or not to do a series of short
kind of responses or kind of one
cohesive
um big thing again that is up to you we
trust
you to use that space to really reflect
what you want us to know about you
so i want to empower you to take that
space and make it your own
to unpack this exercise a little bit
further
um this is something we did yesterday
again referring back to uh
sharing your story one starting your
story
um where you can use this as an exercise
to think about okay
what am i learning about myself from
from that that thing that i just thought
about
what can i do next with it so splitting
this up into a process
and outcomes was that the answer you
expected
from there you can ask things like why
did this answer go that way did it take
a left turn
did it take a u-turn um did it stay like
straightened through on on track to what
you thought it was gonna be
if it was different how maybe the track
still went in the same direction
generally but there's a couple wiggles
in there
what does that mean for how you're
thinking about that
and i think this part's also important
how did you feel
right registering the way your body
responds can often help you understand
okay
where are places that could be
interesting uh to go and explore a
little further right in that spirit of
the self-discovery maybe going somewhere
a little uncomfortable and going into
that personal stretch zone
so when or where was was it harder and
then on the other side of the spectrum
where was it easier where did you find
that energy and where did that light you
up
because that could be another area to
chase if you if you want to figure out
okay maybe what should i be writing
about
so next if you want to do this
as a further exercise like there's
multiple steps that you could do with
any of these
either try writing for a full two
minutes and just keep that
choose one of these questions write for
the full two minutes
answering it you want a challenge write
for a full
five minutes just keep writing and don't
stop
another version knowing that some folks
are actually verbal processors
uh maybe talk through it talk to
somebody answer them
talk to a screen talk to the wall if you
would like to talk to a friendly face
please feel free to stop this video at
any time that i'm smiling
i will always be there for you to listen
as you practice this so
shifting over into style tips and best
practices we're just going to go
straight
there if you're planning for the future
maybe you are
thinking maybe one or two years away
maybe you're just not sure
you can still prepare so practice and
practice developing your written voice
and that just means practice
write things down there are definitely
journals out there that have
built-in questions that you respond to
maybe you have a personal kind of
blog or something you do every day like
practice
it's going to get easier and easier i
know for many of us out there
there might be cultural familial
community
talking about yourself might feel a
little uncomfortable
and in the application process
we want to know about you like if that
hasn't been clear yet like i want you to
embrace that and take in this invitation
to really focus on yourself in this
allow yourself to have that exploration
make time for that introspection
and do it i'll read read anything i am a
big proponent of reading
that's how you absorb and see how other
people use language
and from there that can often help how
you know help inform the way that you
write
type and think once you're in the weeds
of the application there's a couple
things here that i would definitely
highlight as well
consider your audience you might be an
expert in your field
and i we have seen a whole lot of fields
and you might be doing something that
you know
might be very niche
what are ways that you can translate
some of those things
into something that anybody can
understand so that if you're talking to
a stranger on the street
or if your grandmother or someone who
has no understanding of what you do
you could explain to them and they could
say oh yeah
that makes sense i get it it's possible
and remember you know think about who's
on the other side
i would also include this as sometimes
there might be slang or
when you're thinking how can like how
formal how informal can i be
this is still a business school
application you want to put a
professional for
forward but that doesn't necessarily
mean everything has to be formal
language
it doesn't have to have necessarily a
formal structure
the what matters why essay in particular
lends itself to a little bit of creative
license
if that's where you want to go if you
would like to convey it in a you know
intro body body body pose kind of
structure and that works for you
go there right so just know that this
audience
professional foot forward when when is
technical too technical i
refer to that a little bit acronyms will
also fall under this umbrella
so make sure you spell things out or are
there other ways to communicate what it
is
especially if it's very important if
there's not and it's very important
additional information could be a place
to go
but don't use additional information as
a glossary
uh for acronyms so that you could save
space later on you want people to know
what's
going on in any single spot of your
application to the extent possible
i mentioned you don't have to write the
same way in each one
what matters most and the optional
responses are a great example of that
where what matters most you can use a
little bit more free form language
be a little bit more informal um you can
be more direct and really just tell us
what the details are
in some of these space where you have
less space
and through it all the best voice is
your own and that's why i said earlier
like
practice write in a way that feels
natural to you
there's a difference between
constructive feedback stanford
is a huge place for feedback as long as
you're
that final thought and intent and
idea is yours if you become
too if other people's ideas
start to cloud that if there are other
contributions there
other than your own you know that's
where it becomes inappropriate coaching
um and sometimes that's the place where
we actually you lose some of the most
interesting and kind of transparent
authentic genuine elements of who you
are so
feedback great be true to yourself
use your own voice and trust your
judgment through this
okay more tips and takeaways because i
am all about that today
um if you need to push writing mix it up
try walking
sometimes walking um can help jog your
memory or jog
hydrate your creative juices pun not
originally intended but i'm gonna go
with it
um i'm someone who processes by movement
so lean into that for some folks
speaking might be better
take a recorder record your voice use a
transponder you know type it down
afterwards whatever works for you go
there
resist the urge to copy and paste and
here
not so much because you know a name
might be lifted from one application to
another
but each school has a different spirit
energy and thing that might draw you to
them
so if you're writing you know a fresh
response for that school
that helps you channel that and ensure
that you know it doesn't feel
generic or something that can be applied
anywhere and that's going to be of great
service both to you
as well as whatever admission officer is
reading it afterwards
that'll help them see you as someone in
their community
again reinforcing the idea it's not how
quote-unquote good or bad
your writing is because that's
subjective what i'm looking in your
reading for is
what can i learn in your writing um what
i'm reading your writing for is what can
i learn about you
and that is where kind of that maximum
value is
what you want us to know is always gonna
be better than what you think i want to
know
this goes for both how you convey and
what you tell me about
your past experiences in your resume
what and how you write in any of your
responses
i do not have any any
preferences here you have ownership i
know there's a lot of questions in the
chat
in the q a about do we have preferences
on how we approach things
the answer is no we want to make sure
you have enough
license enough landscape a blank canvas
to really let us know who you are
and i know that can be both um kind of
liberating or terrifying depending on
the way you approach it
but i think it can be a great
opportunity
stand up own that story
if in doubt if you're not sure where
something is going maybe
it feels like something has gone off
track but you're not sure what it is
ask yourself so what why am i even
writing about this
what is the message i'm trying to convey
here um
does this actually sound like something
else i've written in this kind of piece
here so
can i change it should i change it so
what
that can be an incredibly powerful tool
to check yourself step back
and look at things from fresh lenses
i'll say it once i'll say it again be
true to your journey
yours is the one that we want to learn
about yours is the one we want to
hear from and i'm gonna leave you with
these
parting words before we jump into this
the q a box
everyone has a different journey to
stanford
everyone has their own journey to
stanford
so will you
take that let that settle in let that
simmer
if you haven't done so already and of
course i'm gonna go into this plug space
to
mix it up from that feel good is check
out my stanford.nba
this can be a great place for you to
learn more there's an application
tracker
um and so great tool
but another great tool that i really
enjoy is that q a box so that's where
i'm gonna head to
next so
i refer to it here there's a question
what if there's multiple things that
are important to you does it have to be
one thing um
like i said there's creative license for
some people yeah it might be a lot of
things
is there something that encapsulates
that um technically
the word the phrase one thing suggests
one thing
so again however you want to approach
this
i have no preference take it
take it around what matters that you're
right it doesn't even say what's one
thing that matters
hey go with a question
um does admissions view non-standard
writing um say interwoven poetry for
example
use it judiciously i have seen instances
where
quotes excerpts you know pro something
more creative has been inserted
um but you also don't want to have
something dominated by that this is not
a creative writing program that you're
applying to
um as long as you're answering the
question and i know what you're
what i'm getting out of it and i know
what your response is kind of that's the
core
of uh the style and the extra elements
that you want to put into there
um if you do decide to go a little bit
more creative
this might be an instance when you think
about you know also showing that you can
be
direct and clear in other spaces of your
application
right so even thinking about you know
this is how it's really meaningful for
me and i
i want to express myself this way and i
can also talk this way
up to you um
so from nikita uh mentioned you never
know
when i referred to you never know if
something might be triggering for
someone else
um sometimes there might be details
sometimes if they're very graphic
details about
um instances where there might have been
violence or other
or situations like that if someone
is reading that or hearing that it might
bring them to that space and also
make them feel uncomfortable
it's okay to write about difficult
instances in your life
what i would say is keep it at the level
of detail so that we
understand what happens you don't have
to go into that graphic element
but you know just enough so that we know
and that is just a general
kind of guideline that i i offer to
people
you don't have to take it but remember
this is
almost like a one-page conversation that
we're having with each other
and you know you also want that person
on the other side to
feel comfortable as they're reading
yours so i would also use that as a
plug for you know if i'm talking about
something controversial
don't be controversial to get a rise out
of someone to get their attention
it's about what am i learning about you
from this process
hopefully that was helpful i know um
that can be a kind of fine line to draw
but again trust your
best judgment there um question from
daniel
uh my from my exercise is it more
appropriate than your or should you
be for primary job ah so how much detail
like when we're asking about what is
your primary job responsibility
um that is one where i would say we're
asking about your job responsibility so
that can definitely be where you put
um manages aquatic conservation programs
but in terms of like bullet
i was um more referring to like bullet
points on your resume
and because that's where we want to know
what you did and even in impact
questions
you know um re you got the got it right
when you were interpreting that question
all right and then in terms of the
process and i want to
kind of come back to the holistic review
process and
i know that this has been a recurring
theme um
it doesn't really matter which part of
the application we're reading first
because we're going to be looking at
every single piece of it together
to understand who you are no one part
is that gateway piece not even an
interview right
it can feel like sometimes that
interview doesn't make it or break it
but that's not how it works we'll hear
back from the
interviewer and then we'll look at that
kind of report
in conjunction with everything that you
submitted same goes for this application
so if you think your way through it we
want to know you
throughout so take yourself out from
that mindset
take ownership of the things that you
can do here and please know that we are
reading with your best intent in mind we
are reading to admit
not to deny and so with that thank you
so much for joining us hopefully this
was helpful hopefully i didn't inundate
you with too many details
um if you have questions we have many
more events both this week
and throughout the summer above and feel
free to send our office any questions
comments that you might have as well as
feedback it helps us provide
events like this that can be as helpful
for you as possible
thank you stay safe